[la musique]
je m'appelle leonid alexandrovitch
Ignatenko j'ai mis la main sur 1949 en 4
ans après la fin du grand
guerre patriotique née dans le sud
L'Ukraine près de la ville de Nikopol
J'ai été 10 ans et je ne suis allé nulle part et mon
Je voulais en quelque sorte voir ces pays
villes que nos soldats ont libérées
ces lieux de tragédie qui sont encore
conservé pour voir comment il vit
l'Europe moderne est la façon dont les gens vivent
ils respirent ce qui les intéresse
connaissance de connaissances nouvelles et connues 3
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes rencontrer des gens intéressants
les gens c'est très excitant
[la musique]
l'art peut être 200 tout pour moi
au moment de la vie le plus intéressant
il semble quand l'art vit quand il
développe des émotions
les pensées que vous transmettez par le biais de
que déjà les descendants peuvent appeler
art ou pas art et quand
vraiment important
devient art et les gens nous sommes quelque chose
comme les gens trouvent leur réponse
les yeux du cœur alors je suis content que ce soit
vient et ce dont les gens sont capables aujourd'hui
apprécier des choses aussi importantes
[la musique]
j'ai toujours évité
d'âge conscient, ces guerres
les sujets me faisaient très mal et j'avais peur
peut-être qu'elle avait peur de se faire mal
une douleur supplémentaire
s'approcha consciemment de lui, réalisant que
vous devez toucher ce sujet pour vous-même pour
compréhension de la vie, vous pouvez être plus profond
que ce qui est maintenant malgré
les difficultés rencontrées par nos
les proches
La Grande Union Patriotique nous unit et
nous donne une compréhension de ce que la vie donne
nous comprenons à quel point il est important d'honorer les autres
les gens combien important et d'honorer leur vie et
si un tel héroïsme qu'est-ce qu'un exploit
[la musique]
Brest c'est d'abord Brest
une forteresse qui le 22 juin 1941
a pris le coup le plus dur
[la musique]
la garnison qui se tenait dans la forteresse
combattu jusqu'au bout
presque tous les défenseurs de la forteresse anglaise
les gens sont morts délibérément
ils ont délibérément accompli des exploits
donner l'exemple à toute l'Armée rouge
savait très bien à l'époque que
peu de chance de survie et très peu de chance
rentrer chez eux, mais néanmoins ils
remplir pleinement mon devoir de soldat
jusqu'à la fin ils le comprennent parfaitement
juste le début de la guerre
ces événements sont certes loin de nous, mais sur
en fait
l'échelle de tous les temps n'est pas si vie
très fugace et fragile tout peut
revenir et il est donc important de se rappeler que
quel était l'événement parce que
la plupart des jeunes
perd train nos vieux meurent
qui étaient des enfants de la guerre qui étaient
participants à la guerre et bien sûr c'est un souvenir
de nombreuses familles perdent des jeunes
qui grandissent et ne peuvent s'empêcher de savoir
l'histoire et pas très au sérieux de ne pas
traiter par besoin de voir ce qui s'est passé
il y a 75 ans ce qui s'est passé il y a 175 ans
quelle était l'histoire comment était-ce quoi
coulé à ce qui a conduit à comprendre ce
étudiez-le et vous pourrez en faire plus
des conclusions complètes doivent pouvoir
percevoir l'expérience percevoir l'histoire et
ne tirez pas de conclusions superficielles
sur ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
monde
[la musique]
me voici à minsk
c'est là que mon voyage commence
[la musique]
Je voulais commencer mon voyage
de la forteresse de Brest
pourquoi parce que je voudrais transmettre
la façon dont ils passaient leur temps
guerre des libérateurs 1944 45e
années
[la musique]
quand j'ai pensé à comment créer ça
le travail que je voulais faire
il était vivant avant qu'elle ne déménage
avec toi pour que tu te sentes
comme s'il était plongé, il voulait créer
à partir de deux dimensions
de l'image en trois dimensions en raison du volume et
quadridimensionnel dû au temps
message instinctif très important
pour nous, nous devons dans le monde moderne que
Mercredi est quelque chose sur ce que nous rapportons
Que penserions-nous si nous étions coincés
coin deviné que je peux et sur la façon dont nous
vivre cette vie maintenant ou nous le ferions
voulait changer quelque chose ou nous
J'aimerais vivre cette journée autrement
faire une bonne action que nous
accidentellement n'a pas fait aujourd'hui en passant
comment vivrait-il pour lui-même
forteresse de Brest vraiment honnête
construit sous le roi de la brique rouge
qui à l'époque était gardé
et c'était juste inaccessible pour un moment
Grande guerre patriotique et juste
défoncés du mieux qu'ils ont pu pour sortir de là
les soldats restants et ont mis le feu à celui-ci
un exploit qui est né de ce rouge
forteresses dans cette flamme rouge
nous voulions écrire un exploit
né de la flamme
courageusement la garnison de leur forteresse
s'est battu pendant près de deux mois
Sans nourriture, sans eau, les gens souffraient et mouraient.
mais a combattu l'un des derniers
les défenseurs de la forteresse ont écrit sur le mur
mourir mais ne pas abandonner
au revoir lettrage de la patrie qui
forteresse de Brest préservée ils
faire d'abord une impression
parce qu'ils ont transféré toutes les forces et
résilience quand les gens écrivent sur ce que nous sommes
nous mourons mais nous n'abandonnons pas
fin vous comprenez que les gens avec complet
revient en pleine préparation sont allés ils sont allés
au combat sans penser à moi sans penser à quoi
plus loin il y avait des inscriptions qui étaient
abandonné au début de la guerre
et en plus il y avait des inscriptions qui étaient
abandonnés à la fin de la guerre par des gens qui
atteint le point final 300
norris il y en avait un grand nombre
inscriptions de gens ordinaires russes de leur
les textes ont été choisis les lettres ont été collectées
une police si commune qu'ils l'ont appelée
mai et cette police que vous vouliez
perpétuer et dans notre image et nous
représenté un petit extrait
peut faire la police
chaque lettre est unique dans sa propre écriture
avec ton inclination avec ton humeur
comme si cette armée était avec nous sur nous sommes ensemble avec
leur
[la musique]